HER, YOU CAN MAKE THE WEATHER
ABOUT THE RUSSIANS.
[APPLAUSE]
WHAT DID WE GET IF YOUR NAME WAS
CLIFF SIMS?
TWO WEEKS AGO YOU WERE NOBODY,
ZERO, YOU SAY MY NAME IS CLIFF
AND PEOPLE WOULD LAUGH BECAUSE
IT'S A FUNNY NAME.
NAMED AFTER IRAQ FORMATION AND
IN A COMPUTER GAME.
BUT IT'S AMAZING WHAT A TELL ALL
WILL DO FOR NAME RECOGNITION.
>> CLIFF SIMS DURING THE NOW.
>> MY MAIN GOAL IS TO HAVE AS
MUCH FUN AS THE MOOD.
>> IT WAS THE "GAME OF THRONES",
BACKSTABBING,.
>> BEAUTIFUL LIFE, MARBLE
BATHROOM.
>> I JUST SAW SEAN SPICER TOTING
A REFRIGERATOR OUT OF HERE WITH
A CORD DANGLING.
>> NEW SINGLE EAR WHICH WE PAID
FOR WITH HIS OWN MONEY AND THE
ATMOSPHERE IS LIKE, CAN YOU
BELIEVE IT?
GREG: WOULD YOU LOOK AT THAT --
THE SKY GETS MORE AIRTIME THAN A
FRISBEE AT A FISH CONCERT.
NOT HIS FAULT.
HE'S JUST GIVING THE LOCKSTEP
LEMMINGS WITH WHAT THEY WANT, IT
DOESN'T MATTER IF WHAT THEY
GOBBLE UP THIS IS AN CRAP THEY
INHALED A MONTH BEFORE.
CLIFF SIMS, FORMER WHITE HOUSE
STAFFER IS NOW CLIFF SIMS,
SUPERSTAR.
FOR A WEEK.
WHY?
BECAUSE HE IS A THINK.
HIS TELL-ALL HAS ALL THE
SHOCKING DETAILS.
GET THIS.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE PRESIDENT USES
TRESSA MAY EXTRA OLD HAIRSPRAY.
[LAUGHTER]
I KNOW.
FANCY.
FIVE DOLLARS.
POPULAR HAIRSPRAY FOR AVERAGE
JOE'S WITH ORANGE HAIR.
GET THIS.
TRUMP WOULD OFTEN POINT OUT TO
OVAL OFFICE VISITORS WHERE
CLINTON AND MONICA LEWINSKY HAD
SEX.
[LAUGHTER]
WHO WOULD NOT DO THAT?
IT'S LIKE THE MOST INTERESTING
THING TO HAPPEN IN THE OVAL
OFFICE.
IT'S A STAIN ON OUR HISTORY AND
THE OFFICE RUG.
[LAUGHTER]
THE MEDIA WAITED BREATHLESSLY ON
A TIMED LEGS RUBBING UP AGAINST
CLIFF'S KNEES FOR SCRAPS.
IT IS MORE ABOUT THE MEDIA THAN
SIMS WHO THEY USE LIKE A BLOWUP
DOLL PUNCH IN AND PUNCH OUT AND
TOSSING THEM ONTO THE PILE OF
DARK WHO CAME BEFORE HIM.
THE MEDIA WONDERS MIGHT BE OF
SUCH A LOW OPINION OF THE MEDIA
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A LOW OPINION
OF YOU.
THEY WANT -- THEY THINK WE WANT
THIS.
WORSE, THEY THINK IT MATTERS
BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL NURSING
BRUISES FROM 2016 THE FIGHT REST
OF US FELT THAT IF I'D WHEN THE
DAILY TELEGRAPH HAD TO APOLOGIZE
AND PAY MONEY TO MELANIA TRUMP
ABOUT MAKING A [BLEEP] ABOUT
HER.
SOME OF THE CRAP WAS TAKEN FROM
A PREVIOUS TELL-ALL WHICH
CONTAINED THE.
REPORTER: OF OTHERS.
IMAGINE THAT.
AND UNRELIABLE TELL-ALL.
HOW CAN THAT BE?
TELL-ALL NEVER PUT THE SUBJECT
IN A GOOD LIGHT AND THAT IS WHY
IT'S ALWAYS A SHOCKING TELL-ALL.
NOT A FLATTERING TELL-ALL.
AS A BOSS, I KNOW I CAN BE A
TARGET OF SUCH THINGS.
BUT DOING A DOCUMENTARY ON ME
RIGHT NOW AND IT IS NOT PRETTY.
>> WHAT'S IT LIKE TO WORK FOR
GREG?
>> WELL, ONE DAY LAST YEAR HE
MADE ME RELATE.
IT WAS MY BIRTHDAY AND HE KNEW
THAT I WANTED TO GO OUT WITH MY
FRIENDS AND HE SAID NO, YOU
STILL HAVE TO WORK ANYWAY.
HE SAID IT WAS IMPORTANT.
HE SENT ME DOWNTOWN TO GO PICK
UP A PACKAGE FOR HIM AND WHEN I
GOT THERE HE HAD THROWN THIS
HUGE SURPRISE PARTY FOR ME AND
ALL MY FRIENDS AND FAMILY WERE
THERE.
ERICA ESTRADA WAS THERE SIGNING
AUTOGRAPHS FOR PEOPLE AND HOW
DID GREG KNOW THAT ERIC WILL
START OUT WITH MY LONG-LOST
HALF-BROTHER?
BEST BIRTHDAY EVER HAPPENED WHEN
ASKED PEOPLE HOW GREG PULLED
THIS OFF AND WHY WASN'T HE
THERE, THEY TOLD ME HE WAS AT MY
APARTMENT WATERING MY PLANTS
BECAUSE HE KNEW I WOULD NOT DO
THAT NIGHT.
WHAT A GUY.
GREG: THAT WAS NOT SO BAD.
FACT IS, IF YOU CAN CLAP FOR ME.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: NOT OVER.
BASICALLY, A TELL-ALL RELIES ON
TRASH AND A LOW-LEVEL GARBAGEMAN
WHO NEEDS MONEY TO OFFER SUCH
TRASH BECAUSE NO PUBLISHER WILL
FORK OUT THE DOUGH TO A BOOK
CALLED MEETINGS WITH TRUMP, HE'S
ALSO BEEN TRASHING THE SUBJECT
IS THE BUSINESS MODEL WHICH IS
NOW STRETCH FOR TWO YEARS.
YOU CAN'T DO A TELL-ALL ABOUT A
BORING PERSON.
CHAPTER ONE, HE STRETCHED.
IMAGINE A TELL ALL ABOUT MIKE
PENCE.
RUMOR HAS IT HIS WIFE ONCE
CALLED HIM LOOKING AT ANOTHER
WOMAN.
IT WAS THE VIRGIN MARY.
[LAUGHTER]
NOPE, IF YOU LIVE A LIFE THERE
WILL BE TORPID HERE IS ONE OF MY
STAFF IS SAYING ABOUT ME.
>> ONE TIME HE INVITED ME TO HIS
OFFICE AND IT WAS LATE AND WE
WERE ALONE.
ONE THING LED TO ANOTHER AND HE
FOUND MY CALF AND HE JUST GONE
MISSING THE DAY BEFORE.
I WAS SO GRATEFUL.
THEN WHEN I GOT HOME I SAW HE
MADE A DONATION TO A LOCAL
HOSPITAL IN MY NAME.
HE NEVER EVEN MENTIONED IT.
HE ALSO DID MY LAUNDRY.
GREG: THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
WORSE.
THE MEDIA GETS THE AIR INJECTION
OF GOSSIP AND BEFORE HE GETS TO
BUNK THEY MOVED ON.
CLIFF SIMS WAS A LOW-LEVEL HACK
BUT THEY CAN GO EVEN LOWER.
THE NEXT BOOKS ARE GROUNDS FOR
IMPEACHMENT AS TOLD BY THE WHITE
HOUSE GARDENER.
BOILING OVER, I BURNED TRUMPS
STAKES IN 12 OTHER CHAPTERS.
INSIDE TRUMP, A MEMOIR WITH
COLONOSCOPIES.
FACT IS, EVERYONE HAS SOMETHING
TO SAY AND FRANKLY, THAT WORRIES
ME.
>> YEAH, ONE TIME I WAS REALLY
LATE AND MY TRAIN WAS DELAYED BY
THE TIME I GOT THERE, GREG WAS
IN MY OFFICE.
HE LOOKED PI AS A CD.
THEN HE LOOKED AT ME AND SAID I
THOUGHT YOU WERE DEAD AND HE GOT
UP AND HUGS ME.
THE BIGGEST, BEST DOG I EVER
HAD.
BETTER THAN MY DAD'S HUG.
THEN HE PULLED OUT HIS WALLET
AND GAVE ME $600 FOR NO REASON.
GREG: THE RICHER THE LIFE, THE
JUICIER THE TELL-ALL.
WHICH IS WHY NO ONE WILL CARE
ABOUT THAT JIM ACOSTA TELL-ALL.
BY THE WAY, IT'S CALLED MY ANGRY
CARE FOR SLEEP APNEA.
NO ONE IN THE MEDIA WILL EVER
GET A TELL-ALL LIKE THE ONES
THEY GET ABOUT TRUMP WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT
TRUMP?
HE IS INTERESTING.
THE MEDIA IS NOT EVEN CLOSE.
WELL, EXCEPT FOR ME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> OH, YEAH, SURE.
BACK IN 2012 I WAS ON THE WAY TO
THE HOUSE AND ABOUT TO KNOCK ON
THE DOOR I HEARD SCREAMING.
I KNEW IT WASN'T GREG'S SCREAMS
BECAUSE I KNOW GREG SCREAMS BUT
IT KEPT GETTING LOUDER AND
LOUDER SO I KICKED IN THE DOOR
AND WHAT I SAW WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
GREG WAS DELIVERING A BABY,
APPARENTLY WHEN HE'S NOT AT FOX
GREAT VOLUNTEERS AS A MIDWIFE.
I APOLOGIZE ABOUT THE DOOR AND
HE SAID DON'T WORRY, I WAS GOING
TO HAVE IT REPLACED WITH HERE
HAVE A HOKEY AND THEN HE GAVE ME
$600.
>> OH YEAH.
LAST MONTH I WAS PRETTY
CONVINCED GREG HAD A DRAGGING
PROBLEM AND HE WOULD ONLY DRINK
SEVERAL GLASSES OF WATER A DAY
AND WHEN I TOLD HIM YOU SHOULD
DRINK EIGHT, HE TOOK MY ADVICE
AND THEN DOUBLED MY SALARY.
NOW, I CAN QUIT MY NIGHT JOB AT
THE REFINERY AND SPEND MORE TIME
VOLUNTEERING AT THE ORPHANAGE
GREG FOUND IT.
>> OH YEAH, WELL, I DON'T LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT IT THAT MUCH BUT
BACK IN THE EARLY DAYS THERE
WERE LATE NIGHTS AND GREG GOT ME
HOOKED ON DRUGS BABY ASPIRIN.
NO EVERYDAY I TAKE A BABY
ASPIRIN BECAUSE IT REDUCES YOUR
HEART DISEASE.
I DID NOT DO THAT AT THE TIME
BUT BEFORE THAT GREG GUTFELD SO
GREG PRACTICED MEDICINE AT THIS
ORPHANAGE HE FOUNDED.
HE ALSO GAVE ME $600 ONCE.
♪.
GREG: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
HOMELESS PEOPLE GIVE HIM CHANGE,
COMEDIAN JIMMY.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
TRY SAYING HER NAME JOHN,
FOXBUSINESS REPORTER CHRISTINA.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SHE CHEERED AT THE END OF OLD
YELLER, KAT TIMPF.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
AND THE EIFFEL TOWER IS HIS GOLF
CLUB, FORMER WWE SUPERSTAR IN MY
MASSIVE SIDEKICK, TYRUS.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
JIMMY, GOOD TO SEE YOU DRESSED
UP.
TODAY'S MAN IS SUITING YOU.
>> YOU'RE KILLING ME, MAN.
DON'T ASSUME MY GENDER.
GREG: IS TELL-ALL, THOUGH THEY
NEED TO STEP IT UP BECAUSE I
FEEL LIKE THEY ARE --
>> OF THE HONEST, I'M NOT READ
THE TELL-ALL SPIRIT AND WAITING
FOR THE BOX SET TO COME OUT.
WHEN YOU DO GO TO SELL THESE
BOOKS YOU HAVE TO GET THE
PUBLISHER INTERESTED.
THEY DO A LOT OF EMBELLISHING.
I KNOW THIS.
I HAVE A BOOK OUT CALLED FOLLOW
THAT CAR, IF YOU LIKE READING AT
A THIRD LEVEL YOU LIKE THIS
BOOK.
AT THE SAME TIME AS YOU READ THE
INNER WORKINGS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION YOU'RE
APPRECIATIVE OF IT BECAUSE CAN
YOU IMAGINE HOW BORING THE
TELL-ALL ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON
WOULD BE.
THE ONLY INTERESTING CHAPTER
WOULD BE WHEN THE COMPUTERS GOT
A VIRUS BECAUSE SOMEONE LET
ANTHONY WEINER USE THE WI-FI.
>> IT SHOULD EVENT WHICH COLOR
POWER SUIT SHOULD SHE WEAR THAT
DAY.
GREG: THAT IS QUITE A POWER SUI
SUIT.
>> IT'S A ONESIE.
GREG: CHRISTINA, YOU'RE A
BUSINESS PERSON OR SO I AM TOLD.
THIS IS A BUSINESS.
TRUMP IS BASICALLY REVITALIZING
THE TELL-ALL.
>> WHY NOT CAPITALIZE?
YOU ARE SEEING UP POLITICAL
BOOKS CLIMB 25% IN LAST YEAR.
EVEN IF YOU JUST LET HIM DRIVE
BY OR YOU'RE THE GARDENER OR THE
CAR, WHY NOT WRITE A BOOK?
EVERYBODY HAS WRITTEN ONE AND
I'VE READ ONE BY BOB WOODWARD,
THERE IS NOTHING IN IT THAT WAS
ANYTHING EXCITING OR ANYTHING
YOU COULD REALLY WRITE ABOUT.
GREG: I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU,
WHO WOULD YOU RATHER BE, THE
SUBJECT OF A TELL-ALL OR THE
WRITER OF A TELL-ALL AND THEN I
REALIZED OCCUPY THE SAME SPACE?
BECAUSE YOU'RE YOUR OWN TELL-AL
TELL-ALL.
KAT: I REALLY WHERE ALL MY
SECRETS ON MY SLEEVE AND THEN
I'M LIKE WHY DOESN'T ANYONE LIKE
ME?
THIS WAS NOT SHOCKING.
MORE OF THE SAME.
THINGS WERE A LITTLE CRAZY IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE KNEW THAT ALREADY.
THAT WOULD BE LIKE SOMEONE
WRITING A TELL-ALL ABOUT THE
KARDASHIANS THAT WERE LIKE THEY
WEAR MAKEUP.
[LAUGHTER]
NOT THAT SHOCKING.
IT BE SHOCKING IF SOMEONE CAME
OUT WITH A BOOK THAT THAT I WORK
FOR TRUMP AND I WAS BORED.
AND HE ATE A LOT OF SALAD.
THAT WOULD SHOCK ME BUT THE
THING IS NO MATTER HOW MANY OF
THESE BOOKS COME OUT IT DOES NOT
MATTER AS NO ONE REALLY CARES.
THE PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT WILL SUPPORT HIM NO
MATTER WHAT IS GOING ON BECAUSE
THEY LIKE HIS POLICY PROPOSALS
AN AGENDA AND THAT IS ALL THAT
MATTERS TO THEM.
IT'S A WASTE.
GREG: IT IS.
I WOULD SAY THIS, TYRUS, I
ENJOYED THE TIDBITS BUT THEY
MEAN NOTHING TO ME.
TYRUS: REALLY, GREG?
LITTLE TIDBITS IN A TELL-ALL ME
NOTHING.
GREG: WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO
INFER?
TYRUS: MY TELL-ALL IS IT UP
THERE.
ISN'T THAT CRAZY?
I DIDN'T GET -- YOU ASKED EVERY
EMPLOYEE AND NO ONE KNEW WHO
HOLLY WAS BUT THEY DO NOW.
[LAUGHTER]
WHY WAS I NOT ASKED?
GREG: YOU DON'T LIVE IN NEW YOR
YORK.
TYRUS: I'VE BEEN HERE SINCE
WEDNESDAY, SIR.
IT MUST BE NICE.
MR. PRESIDENT, TAKE A PAGE OUT
OF THE GREG GUTFELD LINE.
HE DID HIS OWN TELL-ALL.
HE DIRECTED IT.
HE PRODUCED IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU NOTICED BUT
THAT MUFFLED VOICE THAT WAS
HOLDING THOSE PEOPLE HOSTAGE FOR
HOURS, THAT WAS GREG.
HE SAT WHILE HE TALKED ABOUT HOW
GREAT HE WAS.
WHAT'S THE NAME OF YOUR
ORPHANAGE?
I NEVER CAUGHT THE NAME OF IT.
GREG: THAT'S IT.
GREG'S ORPHANAGE.
GOOGLE IT.
TYRUS: ANYONE WANT TO GOOGLE
THAT?
[LAUGHTER]
MY POINT IS, TELL-ALL'S ARE
[BLEEP].
GREG: THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THAT LEAVES MORE TIME FOR THE
NEXT SEGMENT.
BEFORE WE GO, AN UPDATE ON THE
GUTFELD MONOLOGUES LIFE.
THE SHOW IN TAMPA IS SOLD OUT.
I NEVER SOLD OUT ANYTHING.